[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARJUNA ARDAGH:
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
For me, it's really a
very awesome experience
to speak at Google because
Google, as a company,
so much represents the vision
that this book is about.
I have coached people on and
off from Google over the years.
And this book, in a
way, is drawn very much
on my experience of Googlers.
And let me just explain
why for a minute.
I mean, just one
thing, I don't know--
do you call it the 20%
rule or the 20% policy,
or how do you refer to that?
Rule sounds a little
intense, but how
do you call that, the 20% thing?
AUDIENCE: 20% time.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: 20% time, yeah.
I mean, that, on its
own, is mind-blowing.
That was definitely
not happening
in the '50s or the '60s
or the '70s or the '80s,
that you get to spend,
as I understand it,
20% of your time doing
what inspires you,
doing what you feel can make
a difference to the planet.
Is that a good way to
summarize that policy?
Yeah.
I mean, that is incredible.
But also just the fact
that we have-- that there's
extraordinarily good food
just on the other side
of those doors and,
down in Mountain View,
incredible recreational
offerings of all kinds.
This is a company
that obviously-- very,
very obviously and overtly--
is not just about people
showing up to get a paycheck.
It's offering an opportunity
for its employees
to innovate and contribute
and create a meaningful life,
as well as to contribute
to the company.
Would that be a good--
would you agree?
Is that what Google's all about?
Yeah.
So that makes it really
inspiring for me.
Because there are
actually, I would
say, relatively few
companies on the planet who
are so upfront and overt
about wanting to create
that kind of environment.
So my experience of working
with Googlers, but also
with other people in the
technology sector, industry,
is that many people find
themselves, I've noticed--
I'd like to know if
this is true for you--
many people find themselves
in an interesting predicament.
And I haven't worked too much.
I haven't worked for
a corporation where
I show up and go away again.
I'm more of a freelance guy.
So the closest parallel
I can find in my own life
to what I hear from
a lot of people
who work for big companies
is, back when I was a teenager
and I was dating, all right?
And I was friends with
this very beautiful girl.
And actually, I may
possibly break down
and cry when I
tell you this story
because it's actually--
it was a big deal for me.
I was friends with this girl
who was incredibly beautiful
in every way.
I mean physically
beautiful, but also
just had an incredible
grace about her,
she was extremely kind.
She was really, as far
as I was concerned,
she was the closest thing
to God in human form.
And I was a teenager.
And I really liked her a lot.
I liked her so
much, I could hardly
imagine that she
could be my girlfriend
or I could be her boyfriend.
It was just like it was an
extraordinary experience
to be close to her.
And so this happened.
We used to go to the same
place for summer holidays.
Our parents would drive us
to this village in Suffolk
on the east coast of
England, in East Anglia,
and we'd have holidays together.
And we were both teenagers.
And I was obsessed
with, is today
going to be the day
I'm going to kiss--
I'm not going to say her name
because this is going out
on YouTube.
But is this going to
be the day that I'm
going to kiss the
object of my longing?
And I remember,
after a few years,
she said something
interesting to me.
She said, you know,
I really like you,
but you try way too hard.
Interesting thing.
She said, I really like
you, but you're obviously
just trying way too hard.
When I see you just
relaxing, I really
feel I want to be close to you.
But when we come
together, you're
trying so hard that, whatever
it is, the beautiful things
you have to offer get
eclipsed by the trying.
Do you get the story?
And that was a very
beautiful thing.
And by that point,
we were so close
that it was like brother and
sister and all bets were off.
So we just developed a
beautiful friendship.
But it was an incredibly
beautiful lesson
that has been replicated for
me again and again in my life.
And I wonder if you've had
any similar experience where,
sometimes, the harder
we try, the more elusive
what we long for becomes.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
Sometimes, you try really
hard, and what you actually
have to offer and what
the situation has to offer
you dissipates a little bit.
And I've noticed that that
same situation I've noticed
gets duplicated
sometimes when you
work for an amazing
company, a company that
has built into its policies
that it wants you to thrive.
And it does everything it can
to provide an environment where
people can thrive.
And then sometimes we find
ourselves just trying too hard.
Does that make sense?
Like, we try hard
to get a promotion.
We try hard to be the
best person we can be.
And all the time, the
situation is set up actually
for us to relax.
And in that relaxation,
our greatest gifts emerge.
Now, give me a little feedback
because if what I've just said
doesn't sound in any
way in the ballpark,
I should completely rewrite
the rest of the talk.
Does that resonate at all?
The pressure for promotion,
the pressure for performance,
the pressure to excel
in the environment
actually can sometimes
negate the very best
of what you have to offer.
Does that make sense?
Give me a little noise so I
know if we're on the right page.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: OK, cool.
Well, that's what I want
to talk about today.
If that resonates with you,
that's what we'll talk about.
If you'd rather talk
about tangerine La Croix,
we could talk about that too.
But that's what I want to talk
about is, how we can overcome
that frustrating gap between the
deepest gifts we have to offer
when we're actually
relaxed and being ourselves
versus the pressure
to perform, all right?
So this slideshow is
set up such that I can't
see what the next slide is.
So I'm going to have to actually
put the slide before I speak.
So when it comes to anything
new entering the world,
like the 20% policy at Google
is really an invitation for you
to be an instrument of something
new entering the world, right?
More or less, it
allows you to innovate.
It allows you to do whatever
you feel is most meaningful.
Did I get that right,
yeah-- or at least
team up with other
people and do that?
When anything new
enters the world, when
anything evolutionary
enters the world,
it has to begin with an event
in consciousness, right?
That's where everything begins.
So the idea of an
incredible search engine
that can access every
website in the world
and bring back results
in milliseconds,
that had to begin with an idea
in Larry or Sergey's head,
right?
Somebody had to think
it before you could even
start to build the
algorithm, correct?
Everything has to begin with
an event in consciousness.
So let's take a really--
let's flesh this out.
Let's take a really obvious
landmark like the Eiffel Tower.
So everyone's heard
of the Eiffel Tower.
The Eiffel Tower
actually, in many ways,
did propel the advancement
of engineering.
Before the Eiffel
Tower, there were
limits on what we
thought was possible.
After the Eiffel Tower, lots
of other similar structures
start to be built.
Well, the Eiffel Tower
had to begin with plans.
Before you could
build a tower, you
had to have plans done
and engineering done.
But the plans could
not be drawn up
before they were a thought,
just a little inkling, just
a twinkle in the eye
of Gustav Eiffel who
was responsible for
the Eiffel Tower.
Scientists who
focus on neurology
estimate that we have about
48 mental events per minute.
That's a little bit
slower than 1 per second.
That means a new
potential mental event
is happening a little
bit more slowly
than once a second,
which means we
have about 48 thoughts
a minute, which
translates to almost
3,000 thoughts
an hour, 70,000 thoughts a day.
How many people work
at Google worldwide?
AUDIENCE: 70,000.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: OK, so
multiply 70,000 by 70,000.
I'm not going to do
that math in my head.
But that's a lot of thoughts
being generated by Googlers
every day, all right--
a lot of mental events
happening every day.
But if we just think of
it in the world, 483,840
billion thoughts every day.
Now, how many of
those thoughts would
you imagine create the
Eiffel Tower or the iPhone
or the laptop
computer or penicillin
or the general
theory of relativity?
What would you imagine?
What percentage of
thoughts, of mental events
do you think turn into
thoughts that actually advance
the evolution of humanity?
What would be your guess?
AUDIENCE: 1%.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: 1%.
AUDIENCE: That's high.
ARJUNA ARDAGH:
That's pretty high.
Think about it, what that means.
If there's--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm an optimist.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: --but if you look
at 483,840 billion thoughts,
you've only got to
take off two zeros.
And you've got 4,838 billion
brilliant thoughts a year--
probably not that much, right,
not that change the world.
It's probably more like,
actually, even 1 in 1 billion
would be optimistic.
Because that would
leave us with 483,000
brilliant life-changing
thoughts a year.
Even that's probably optimistic.
So what you can see is
that, although there
are all these thoughts
being generated,
relatively few turn
into innovation.
Relatively few turn into
something that changes
the game for everybody, right?
If any one of us in
this room could increase
the percentage of
mental events that
go through your consciousness
that translate into something
innovative, that 20% rule would
become a lot more effective,
correct?
So I'm going to
posit to you today,
based on a little research
I've been doing for the last 25
years, 30 years.
I'm going to suggest to you a
little model that we can share,
which, to the degree we've
been able to test it--
myself and my colleagues here--
we've been able to see
it's a fairly reliable way
of increasing the
percentage of radically
brilliant,
life-changing thoughts
which pass through your mind.
Maybe from 1 in 1 billion
to 1 in 1 million.
That would be an
enormous increase, right?
Per year, it's 176,000
trillion thoughts a year
that are generated
all over the planet.
So that's a lot of thoughts.
So in order to understand
this, I want to suggest for you
a little model-- and like every
model, it's an approximation--
a little model of how we
can understand thought.
We can begin to think
of thought in two
ways, two kinds of thought.
Think of it like the waves
on the surface of a pond.
So one kind of thought we
could call horizontal thoughts.
A horizontal thought
means it's a thought that
is generated by another
thought that was already there.
In other words,
it's not original.
It's not arising out of nowhere.
It's a predictable thought that
was conditioned into your mind
by an existing thought.
For example, let's imagine
you go onto social media,
like Google+ where
people share things.
Is that what it's called?
It's called Google+.
I should know that.
Go onto Google+, where people
share things with each other
or any other social
media platform,
some of which I probably
shouldn't mention in the room.
But you go onto a
social media platform.
And you see somebody has put one
of those pictures of a really
old person's hand
holding a baby's hand.
You go, oh, how sweet,
share, like, comment.
Or maybe there's a
sunset, and somebody's
put this kind of thing
like a heart superimposed
on the sunset.
Oh, how beautiful-- share, like,
heart, you know, et cetera.
You know, one of the things
I can never understand,
there's a picture of
a rock in the desert.
Maybe you can help
me out with this.
There's a picture of
a rock in the desert.
And there's a guy wearing
a business suit jumping off
the rock in the desert.
I've never figured out why is
this guy wearing a business
suit jumping off a
rock in the desert?
But never mind,
share, like, you know.
So anyway, you go
onto social media.
And you find an
image of a sunset.
And superimposed in
some of that writing
you can do in one
of these apps, it
says "Before you complain
about anything in your life,
count the things you
can be grateful for."
You go, oh, that's wonderful.
"Before you complain,
count the things--"
and you go share, like,
heart, like, comment, you see?
And that evening, when
your partner comes home,
you say, how was your day?
And your partner
says, it was terrible.
I mean, I left
home late for work.
I got stuck in traffic; there
was some kind of accident.
I got to the office late.
There was a meeting,
which I had to come
into in the middle
of the meeting.
The first thing they said
is where's the report?
I searched around.
I left home too quickly;
I didn't have the report.
It was incredibly humiliating.
I had a bellyache the whole day.
I got a parking ticket.
On the way home,
I had a flat tire.
It was like the worst day ever.
But you remember
that little thing
that you saw earlier in
the day on social media.
And you say, well, honey,
before you complain
about anything in
your life, remember
what you can be grateful for.
However, this is not an
authentic, original, innovative
response to the situation.
It's just
regurgitating a thought
that you read
earlier in the day.
And it doesn't get exactly the
response you were hoping for.
In fact, it might even
earn you a slap, see?
So that's an example of
a horizontal thought.
It's not original.
It's not responding with
genius and creativity
in an unexpected
way to the familiar.
It's just regurgitating
something you've heard before.
It's hard to measure
these things.
But we could guess that almost
all thoughts are like that.
Almost all thoughts
are just repeating
something that has been
programmed into us, correct?
But then there's another kind
of thought, a thought which
is quite rare, which doesn't
get generated by a preceding
thought on the surface.
It arises from deep within us.
And of course, it requires
us to be connected deep
within us in order for that
kind of thought to happen.
But it's a thought that
percolates up from the depths.
It percolates from beyond
the mind, and gains momentum
as it comes to the
surface so that, when
it arises on the
surface, it becomes
the general theory of relativity
or a completely different way
to think of phones.
Or it becomes a way
to end global warming.
It becomes a way to cure cancer.
It becomes a way to
think of things in a way
that we've never thought
of them before, all right?
Now, if we had a way--
if all of us in this
room-- if we had a way
to have more of these
thoughts that bubble up
out of a mysterious source
and give birth into the world
through us, we would benefit
from that in many ways.
Is that true?
Your life would be
extraordinarily meaningful
if you were having
original thoughts that
really contribute.
You would actually
make more money.
You would be way more valuable
to the people you work with.
Everything would get better
if we could become vehicles
of those kind of thoughts.
Are we on the same page?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Good.
Let's move on.
So I've made it my business to
interview a lot of incredibly
brilliant people.
I sought out the most
innovative, brilliant people
I could find in
different fields.
And I did extensive interviews.
I've done by now I think
close to 450 interviews.
It was 420 when I
finished the book,
but I've done a few more since.
And I asked them
questions to find out,
what are the ways
that people live
who are incredibly brilliant?
And some of the ways
they live might not
have an obvious
connection to brilliance.
But if we find a pattern that
brilliant people frequently
do this kind of
thing, we might start
to be able to
discover connections
that we didn't know were there.
So what I've come to
discover, and what
I want to share
with you today is,
brilliance becomes
quite predictable.
It's no longer just an accident.
It becomes predictable
when we can
recognize that brilliance is
actually the byproduct of four
different kinds of
subjective experience-- four
subjective experience,
therefore, four different
kinds of activity,
and also four very different
ways that your brain operates
with different brain
chemicals involved.
So what I'm going
to do now is I'm
going to go through
this cycle and explain
to you the characteristics of
these four different movements.
And as you'll see,
because they're
so different from each other,
and because they involve
completely opposing value sets--
the values in this orange
arrow are the opposite values
of the brown arrow.
In fact, anywhere
you go on this cycle,
the values that are represented
by that position on the cycle
are the complete
opposite of the values
and completely different
beliefs about reality
than the other side
of the cycle, which
partly comes to
explain why brilliance
is so unusual in the world.
Because it requires us
to be able to contain
completely contradictory values
within a human life, right?
So let's start.
I'm going to first
identify four positions
on this cycle,
something like a clock,
with 12:00 at the top,
3:00, 6:00, and 9:00.
When we understand the flavor
of these four positions,
then we can understand
the movements.
But I do want to emphasize,
these stations, 12:00, 3:00,
6:00 and 9:00-- no one stays
in any one station very long.
Just like with a clock,
it's not exactly 12 o'clock
for very long, right?
It's 11:58, 11:59, 11:59
and 45 seconds, 46, 47.
It's only for a split second
that it's exactly 12:00,
and then it becomes
12:01, you see?
So 12:00 isn't a place you stay.
It's a place you pass through.
Does that make sense?
All right.
So I'm going to describe to you
four stations, which are just
places that we pass through.
So the first we
could call awakening.
An awakening means
at least having
fleeting tastes of a
state of consciousness
which is boundaryless--
in other words, to be able
to experience consciousness
in its purity, when it's
not focused on something
with boundaries.
Now, this is probably the most
unusual of these four stations.
It's the one that requires the
most explaining because it's
not everybody's experience.
It is the experience of people
who have focused on mysticism
or what some people call
spirituality or whatever.
It becomes the
focus of people who
are interested in meditation.
But it's not necessarily
a primary focus
for most people in the world.
It means they become interested
in the nature of consciousness
itself.
Now, consciousness
or awareness can
look at an object
with boundaries
and see, oh, it's this big,
this tall, it has this color.
And it can also experience
the same thing in time.
This was not there, not there,
now it's there, now it's there,
now it's not there, not there.
So we tend to experience
things that have
boundaries of time and space.
But that which
experiences the boundaries
of time and space, what
boundaries does that have,
right?
And if we say, well, that also
has boundaries, it's this big,
then you can simply
ask, well, OK,
so if you're aware of this
big, who's aware of that?
And that boundary is
going to drop away.
And there's going to be the
revelation of something which
has less boundaries.
If that process continues,
you have the same experience
as when you walk
over to the window
and look directly upwards.
And what do you see?
If you look through
the buildings
and through the trees,
what do you see?
Help me.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Hm?
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: The horizon.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: The hor--
well, if you look straight up,
you see the sky, right?
And what is the sky?
Tell me, how big is the sky if
you think about going that way?
AUDIENCE: It's limitless.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Limitless, right?
Which actually-- I
don't know about you,
but it kind of blows my mind.
If I try and grock the fact that
you could keep going forever,
and there's no edge to it, it's
almost impossible for your mind
to understand that.
That's what happens
at 12 o'clock.
Except, instead of going
out of the building
and looking up in the
sky, you look internally
to your own nature and
discover that the nature
of consciousness
itself, when it's not
trapped in an experience,
the nature of consciousness
itself is limitless.
Just curious,
because many people
have explored this in one
way or another already,
just let me see for a
second, how many people feel
you've had at least a taste
of that in your life--
a taste of when boundaries
dropped away and there
was something kind of limitless?
It can happen in meditation.
It can happen bungee jumping.
It can happen making love.
It can happen in
all sorts of ways.
The boundaries drop
away, and you feel free
in your consciousness.
So that's 12 o'clock.
The next station is at 3:00.
And 3:00 now is a different
kind of subjective experience,
a different kind
of brain chemistry.
And it's characterized
by creative flow.
A lot has been written about
flow in the last years.
You know, people have been
documenting flow states.
I would suggest to you today
that a flow state is only
a part of brilliance.
It's an essential part.
But if we focus
only on flow states,
we become incredibly creative,
but not necessarily brilliant
in terms of results.
So creative flow-- it's
highly pleasurable.
It's where energy is
flowing through you.
You don't have to do anything.
It's the musicians
jamming together,
and they're just being
played by the music.
It's when you're surfing a
wave, and you just let go,
and the wave carries you.
It's a writer writing
automatically,
doesn't have to make any effort.
Let's just, again, do a check.
How many people feel you've
sometime in some context
been carried away by a creative
flow, and you can just let go,
and it happens on its own?
Great.
So that's 3 o'clock,
creative flow.
The next station at 6:00 is
the station of achievement.
It's achieving material results,
bringing things in on time.
So it's characterized
by taking action.
It's characterized by
boundaries of time and space.
In that way, it's the
opposite of 12:00.
Remember 12:00 was boundaryless.
6:00 is all about boundaries.
It's about budget, agreements,
contracts, deadlines.
It's all about
operating within limits.
And it actually, very
often, creates stress.
Because having to put
yourself within boundaries
and operate within boundaries
and you might be late,
it creates a noradrenaline
response in the brain
and an adrenal response
in the kidneys.
And finally, the last
position is actually--
it is difficult to explain
just as one space, one place.
It's a journey,
which begins, which
I'll explain why in a minute,
it begins with feelings
of limitation and regret.
It begins with feelings of
I could have done better.
And that's not only a thought.
"I could have done
better" is also
that sinking feeling
in your chest.
It's a feeling of shame,
which, if you live in shame,
and you can't get out of
it, it's toxic, right?
If you live in
habitual shame, that's
not a good place to live life.
But on the other hand,
if you never feel shame,
or if you never feel
regret, there's no learning.
Do you agree?
Shame also has a healthy
function in our lives.
So the journey
from 6:00 to 12:00
is a journey from regret--
I messed up, I could
have done better,
I can't believe I did that,
I was rude and abrasive,
I burned myself out, I
burned other people out.
And it moves through
to 9 o'clock,
which is a place of
self-forgiveness, of learning,
of humility.
Now, in fact, to speak
of these stations
is slightly misleading.
Because you don't stay in
any one place for very long.
You're constantly in movement.
So let's look at the movements.
The first movement, the orange
movement-- and incidentally,
at any point, if you start
to examine your life,
or if-- as I'm a coach,
I examine other people's
lives for them.
If you start to look at
your life, at any moment,
you will find yourself somewhere
in one of these four movements,
OK?
Now, we'll find out in a moment.
You may have a
preference for some parts
of the cycle over others.
And that creates an
imbalance in brilliance.
But at any moment, you can
find yourself sitting somewhere
in one of these four movements.
And what tends to happen
is, the movements tend
to get divorced from the cycle.
So we experience the movement
to be what life's about instead
of being part of a cycle.
So let's look at
the first movement.
The first movement
begins right after 12:00.
It begins right after that
moment of boundaryless
transcendence or a
deeply meditative state.
And it begins with the finest
impulses of creative tremor.
That's long before it's become
a thought or a clear idea.
It's just the faintest
tremor like a perfume carried
over the wind from far away--
just something in the air,
just like a faint melody.
And often, we become
desensitized to those kind
of faint tremors.
We're too busy.
We're too getting things
done to even pay attention.
But if we do pay attention,
the first movement
is a movement from that faintest
impulse into creative flow.
As you pay attention
to that impulse,
give it attention,
give it encouragement,
it builds in intensity, and
it becomes creative flow.
But the entire journey
from 12:00 to 3:00
is a journey that is effortless.
It's something that's
happening to you.
The next movement is
the blue movement,
is the movement from flow
to getting things done.
So you start with flowing.
Things are just
happening on their own.
You're surfing the
wave of creativity.
But if you surf it and
move through the cycle,
it becomes productivity.
Now, there's actually a
masculine and a feminine way
to do that based on
different hormones.
If you have a--
you could call it, I suppose,
a masculine and feminine style.
But if you have more
testosterone running
in your body, you're
probably going
to get things done in a
testosterone style, which
means you have a goal, right?
There are obstacles in the way.
Never mind, we're going
to blast through them.
If necessary, we'll
stay up all night.
It doesn't matter.
I'm going to make it alone.
I don't need any help.
We're just going to go.
And that way of thinking
is more associated
with the hormone testosterone.
And of course, if you go back
to the '50s, a lot of business
was run like that.
The more feminine style, if you
have more oxytocin and estrogen
running in your body,
the more feminine style
is to have a feeling of team.
We're in this together.
I've got your back;
you've got mine.
We're going to trust it's
going to work out well.
We're going to move
through this together.
And there's less
of a willingness
to get stressed and
burned out because it's
seen as unproductive.
But either way, whether
we go through a masculine
or a feminine style,
somehow we make our way
to bringing things home on time.
But the closer we
get to 6 o'clock,
the more we start to create
noradrenaline in the brain.
Adrenaline in the kidneys, but
noradrenaline in the brain,
which means the closer
you get to the deadline,
the more you move into
sympathetic nervous system
activity, and you
start to suppress
parasympathetic activity.
You probably know
what that means.
But strong sympathetic
nervous system activity
means you stop noticing if you
need to go to the bathroom.
You stop noticing if your eyes
are itchy or you feel tired.
You stop noticing
if you need to eat.
You stop noticing the effect
you're having on other people.
You just get really driven.
And parasympathetic activity
means you go, oh, whoa,
my back's hurting.
I'm really tired.
I'm actually-- ugh.
And you can keep up sympathetic
dominance for months.
And then, of course,
you have a burnout,
and that creates what's called
parasympathetic flooding, which
is something that I notice a
lot when I work with people
who work under deadlines.
They push and push
and push at 6 o'clock.
When they finally,
either take a break
or are forced to
take a break, there's
this flood of
parasympathetic activity.
And suddenly you
feel terrible, right?
Because all the
symptoms that have
been building up in the body
suddenly flood your system.
And everything's hurting,
including all of your emotions.
And this moves us into
the next phase, OK,
which is-- this can
happen in a mild way.
If you balance your
life, every day
you have a little
nervous breakdown.
You know, at 6 o'clock, it's
like, oh, I did this wrong.
But it takes 15 minutes,
and you're through it.
If you don't do that every
day, if you don't do that
repeatedly, then it
builds up over months,
and then you have
a real breakdown.
But the movement
from 6:00 to 9:00
is the movement from
some kind of regret--
regret for the way
you treated yourself
or regret for the way you
treated other people--
to humility.
Now, there's a little, I
think, very interesting side
note about just after 6:00.
There was a book written
in the 20th century--
if you can remember
back that far--
by Gregory Bateson.
Gregory Bateson,
in my opinion, was
one of the greatest minds
of the 20th century.
He wrote a book called
"Towards an Ecology of Mind."
And in that book, he coined
the word double bind.
And Gregory Bateson
saw double bind
as the inevitable result of
fully participating in life.
So if you really jump
in with both feet--
I'm here; I'm going to fully
give everything I've got--
you're going to inevitably--
not just if you're unlucky--
you're going to inevitably be
faced with impossible choices.
Should I do this?
Or should I do that?
But whichever way
you choose, there's
going to be some regret
about what you didn't do.
I'll give you a
really quick example.
If you watch soap
operas on the TV,
like dramas on the
TV that repeat,
every episode almost invariably
involves a double bind.
That's what makes
drama interesting.
So a typical double
bind would be
someone inherits the
company from their parents.
Their parents have gotten old,
but they inherit the company.
There's a lot of people who
work for the company who've
been with a company for
years, so it's like a family.
But there's also a lot of
family money in the company.
Automation has taken over.
Now what do you do?
Do you let go of the people
because of the automation,
which means you're
letting down families
who've been with the
company for generations?
Or do you keep the people on
and disappoint the shareholders?
Within the double bind,
there's no solution to that.
See the point?
Within that double bind,
you can't please everybody.
Sometimes the double bind
is, do I please other people,
or do I care take
care of my own needs?
But a double bind
means that, once you've
made the decision with the best
faculties you could muster,
there is still regret at
the end of the decision.
And it's that double
bind that moves us
from regret to humility.
By the time you move through the
parasympathetic nervous system
activity, by the time you come
to terms with the double bind,
when you get to 9
o'clock, you're fully
settled in a state of humility.
You realize, I did my best.
I did the best I could do
under the circumstances.
I made some mistakes, but
everybody makes mistakes.
I'm a limited human being
with limited resources,
but I'm a good person,
and I forgive myself.
You see?
That's 9 o'clock, which is, from
a brain chemical standpoint,
is a preponderance
of GABA in the brain.
GABA is the brain
chemical which allows you
to feel it's OK to rest now.
I've given the best
that I could give.
I'm essentially a good person.
And it's OK for me
to take a break.
The last movement is the
movement from that humility
to awakening.
And it begins with an intuition
of something beyond your mind.
It begins with the intuition,
there's a few things I know.
I'm a good person doing
my best, but there's
so much I don't know.
There's so much that
future generations
will know that I don't
have access to just now.
And that feeling
of humility allows
you to have the intuition of
something beyond your mind.
It could be an intuition
of the future of humanity,
like where will we
be in 100 years?
It could be an intuition
of your own deepest nature,
deeper than the
thoughts that limit us.
And it could be a kind
of religious thing,
where you have an
intuition of the divine--
something bigger than the
human, some intelligence
bigger than the human.
But that is the last movement,
and it brings us back--
if you follow that, it brings us
back into moments of awakening.
If it's possible-- and
it's very, very rare--
but if it's possible to
create a human life where
each of these four movements
are active simultaneously
in a life, ideally, where
each of those four movements
is active in a day,
I would suggest,
based on everything I've been
able to track with clients
and other coaches,
brilliance becomes
much more of a
predictable outcome
and much less of an accident.
Because we're accessing
a consciousness
beyond the boundaries
of the human mind
and bringing that
forth in creative flow,
and bringing into
manifestation a willingness
to learn from mistakes, when
those four phases are active,
brilliance becomes
much more likely.
And the corollary
is true that, when
I've interviewed
brilliant people,
you can find evidence of
all of those four phases
in their lives.
So the book that you
have on your seat
gives a lot of examples of that.
We've got a hard
finish at 1 o'clock?
Yeah.
OK, I'll move on through.
So everything I've described to
you so far is nice in theory.
OK?
It's a great theory,
a great model.
In actual fact, you find
almost nobody living all four
of those phases in a
completely balanced way.
It's a little bit like you
go to the acupuncturist.
And theoretically, there
is chi flowing through all
of the meridians in the body.
But actually-- have you ever
been to an acupuncturist--
if you go to the acupuncturist,
they measure your pulses.
They're going to
say, oh, there's
a little deficit in the liver,
a little build-up of energy
in the spleen.
I've never been to
an acupuncturist
where they said,
oh, everything's
perfectly balanced.
And I don't know if anyone's
ever been to an acupuncturist
and been told that.
The nature of the human body
is there's always some excess
and some deficiency.
Well, in the same
way, when we actually
come down on the ground
and work with human beings,
instead of this, we
see that, you see?
Instead of the free flow
of these four movements,
we actually see various
kinds of blockage,
which is kind of
depressing news,
I suppose, relative
to our brilliance.
But relative to our potential,
it's very good news.
It means we can actually start
to map the nature of blockage.
And when we're able to
accurately understand
the nature of blockage,
it means, very simply,
at any particular
moment, either you
are being completely brilliant,
you're being Einstein,
or we can diagnose
some kind of blockage.
You see?
It's very helpful, right?
It's very helpful
as a coaching method
because either you are
just wowing everybody,
it's just flowing
through like genius,
it's just flowing everywhere,
or something is blocked.
And this has become
more and more
and more accurate in
the way that we coach.
We can go, wow.
You can actually--
once you recognize
the flavors of
blockage, it becomes
very easy to diagnose
the blockage,
and then to be
able to free it up.
So we've been able,
as a group-- there
are a couple of my
colleagues here today-- we've
been able to map four
kinds of blockage.
And the four styles of blockage
exist everywhere in the cycle.
So the first is addiction.
Addiction means that we fixate
on one part of the cycle,
and we say, this
is what life is.
The rest of it doesn't exist.
Life is about this.
So you could get
addicted to flow, right?
You could get addicted to flow.
I just want to flow and flow
and flow and flow and flow.
Never mind about
achieving anything.
Never mind about learning.
I just want to be in flow.
That would be an addiction.
See, you can get
addicted to awakening.
That would be a kind
of spiritual life
where all you want is just
limitless consciousness.
I don't ever want
to open my eyes,
just like more and
more om mani padme hum.
See?
That would be a spiritual
addiction, which
is actually a possible thing.
So addiction means that you
pick out one part of the cycle,
and that's where
you choose to live.
Now equally, that can express
itself also as judgment.
And judgment has a
different flavor to it.
Judgment would mean
that you develop
a kind of disdain for a
certain part of the cycle.
I can't believe people do that.
So you could actually imagine
two people, one addicted
to a part of the cycle, the
other one in judgment of it.
I teach a lot in
Germany, so I usually
tell the story as
two German brothers,
that there are two
German brothers.
They graduate from university.
And Hans, Hans is a
very practical guy.
He gets a job with Mercedes.
He's an engineer.
He rises up through the ranks.
He's driving a
great car, he's got
a big house, a lot of money.
Hans is doing great.
But Wolfgang says, I
don't want any of that.
He goes off to India.
He changes his name to Swami
Sri Sri [INAUDIBLE] Maharaj
Sri [INAUDIBLE].
And he comes back in orange
robes and beads and everything.
And they meet.
After a few years, they meet.
And there's Hans in his fancy
car, and his fancy house,
and everything's great, and
the yacht and multiple houses.
And there's now
Wolfgang as the Swami.
And Wolfgang says to
Hans, what are you doing?
What are you doing
with all this stuff?
You're not even a human being
anymore, you're a human doing,
you're a human achieving,
you're a human having.
You need to find god, see?
Because Wolfgang has a
judgment of 6 o'clock.
He has a judgment
of accomplishment.
But meanwhile, Hans says,
what are you doing in India?
Why are you wearing
all that weird stuff?
What's in India?
Is there like a business
opportunity there or something?
Because I don't
get it, why you're
wasting all your time with that.
They have conflicting
values where
each one thinks that the part
of the cycle where they live
is the purpose of life, see?
And most people
you meet, when you
come to recognize the
possibility of this cycle, most
people you meet have given
an inordinate importance
to one part of the cycle
at the expense of the rest.
So that's judgment.
Judgment means you look
at one part of the cycle,
and you go, oh, I
can't believe anybody
wastes their time with that.
And you can do that with
anywhere on the cycle.
The next kind of blockage is
called aspiration resistance.
And that means you look at
somebody doing something,
and you think, that is amazing.
It looks like a magician
pulling a white rabbit out
of a-- how did you do that?
I want to learn to do it.
That's incredible.
But you can never
do it yourself.
So let me give you
a quick example.
Let's take aspiration resistance
in the brown arrow, right?
Aspiration resistance would
mean, you're going up to Marin?
You're going on holiday
to the wine country?
That sounds great.
Oh my goodness, and you
just went for a massage,
and you're going to
Hawaii next week?
Wow, I so admire you.
I really want to learn to
take care of myself too.
I'm going to do that next month.
But this weekend I've got
to work late because I've
got this big deadline, you see?
So that would be
aspiration resistance.
You're not in judgment.
You think it's great to rest;
you just never go around to it
yourself, you see?
Equally, we could go back.
You see, on the blue cycle,
that would be the artist.
Did I ring any bells there?
OK.
That would be the artist who
goes, like, you've actually
managed to finish your novel?
How did you actually finish it?
Well, how much have you written?
783 pages.
I'm only halfway through.
Because that's someone
addicted to creativity.
They want to-- hm?
AUDIENCE: 10 minutes.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: Yeah.
Want to create, create, create.
Getting something finished
at 6 o'clock looks amazing,
but you can never pull it off.
The last kind of blockage
is called looping.
And that's where you
become a specialist
in one part of the cycle.
And you just go round
and round and round
and round and round in that
little tiny area, for example,
like an editor.
You know, an editor is going
to be working at maybe 2:45
or maybe 3:15, just
going do-do-do-do.
That's all they do.
They just go round and round and
round and round in that area.
Or a project manager--
be going round and round
and round at about 4:30,
do-do-do-do-do.
And that's the problem a
little bit of specialization
and people who work
in organizations.
It's more efficient for
people to go around and around
in one little area.
But of course, they
become efficient
as a cog in the machine.
But they lose their
innate brilliance,
which is why the 20% policy
is so brilliant because it
allows people to flourish
as whole human beings.
OK.
So those are four
kinds of blockage.
But remember, there are
also four quadrants, right?
Four kinds of blockage in four
quadrants-- so 4 times 4--
that's going to be a difficult
one for Googlers-- what
do you think?
AUDIENCE: 16.
ARJUNA ARDAGH: 16.
16 kinds of blockage, right?
So it means, as
coaches, we can now
recognize the distinct
flavor of 16 ways
that brilliance gets
blocked, isn't that great?
16 unique styles.
And you start to be
able to smell it.
It's like-- I don't
know if you drink wine.
Personally, the only distinction
that I'm aware of with wine
is red and white.
I know the difference
between red and white.
But when they say, it's a
Merlot, it's not a Chardonnay,
it's a Merlot.
I don't know the difference.
It's red wine or white wine.
I'm a Philistine with wine.
To this day-- I've been
drinking wine all my life--
I can't tell the difference
between the different kinds.
But some people can.
Some people go, ah, it's
a cheeky little wine
with a little back splash of
[? blackberry. ?] I'm going,
what are you talking about?
Yeah, it's a little je
ne sais quoi of Paris.
I'm going, wha-- its
[? just ?] wine, you know?
But anyway, you can get
really refined with this.
Well, I can't do
that with wine, but I
can do that with blockage.
When I coach somebody, I can--
all of us, we're getting
more and more skilled at it--
you can smell the exact
which one of these 16 flavors
is happening.
So let's just move
on to the last piece
of this, which is
the way all of this
becomes really,
really helpful is,
we have a project going called
the Radical Brilliance project.
And we are able, because
more and more people
are involved in this now, we're
able to actually map practice.
Now, what I mean by
practice is anything,
anything that's ever been done
by anybody in the whole history
of humanity which changes
your state of consciousness.
Anything which has
the effect of shifting
your state of consciousness,
we would call a practice.
So meditation is
obviously a practice,
but so is going shopping,
if it changes your state.
So is going swimming.
So is making love.
So is having a glass of wine.
Under the right circumstances,
anything could be a practice.
But what we see now, as
the more this cycle becomes
accurate and verifiable
in experience,
we realize anything that
any human being has ever
done in the history
of all of humanity,
anything we have
ever done that was
intended to change consciousness
fits somewhere into this cycle.
So any consciousness-changing
practice
is actually a
viable way of moving
through a part of the
cycle where you're blocked.
So I'll give you a few examples.
Right after 12:00-- remember,
that was these finest tremors--
you can make a practice
of experiencing pleasure
in your body, like
you deliberately--
oh, there's a little pocket
of pleasure, mm, right there--
so deliberately experiencing
pleasurable sensations
in your body is a way of
amplifying those tremors that
happen soon after 12:00.
Automatic writing
is a practice that
happens somewhere in the
middle of that orange cycle.
Musicians jamming together,
where they're taken over
by the music, that's
a practice that's
going to amplify like, 2:45.
Setting intentions--
there used to be
this thing about the law of
attraction was very popular.
Setting an intention-- I'm
going to do that in the future.
That happens right after 3:00.
It's got all of
the flavor of flow,
but it's got the
future attached to it.
Making agreements-- OK, I'll
have this done by 3 o'clock.
I give you my word, right?
That agreement is
a 4:30 practice.
It's right in the middle
of getting things done.
Pushing through at the last
minute, staying up late,
drinking coffee to
get the deadline met,
that's a practice
sometimes useful at 5:45.
You can see you don't want to
live your whole life that way,
but it's a great practice when
you need to meet a deadline.
Right after 6 o'clock is,
not a very popular practice,
but deliberately feeling pain.
Stopping-- maybe
that's why sometimes
why we go to a therapist.
The therapist helps
you to feel pain
you've been unwilling to feel.
And under the right
circumstances,
it's a great thing to do.
That's a 6:15 practice.
Making atonement-- very popular
in the 12-step movement--
writing letters, I'm really
sorry I did this 30 years ago.
I really feel bad about it.
That's a repairing
practice at 7:30.
Self-forgiveness--
going for a walk
and really thinking about
that you're essentially
a good person, getting in touch
with your essential goodness
and forgiving yourself.
That's an 8:45 practice.
And in the last
segment, prayer, when
you feel very separate from
something outside yourself,
but you ask for help.
That would be a practice
right after 9:00.
Meditation would be
a practice that--
or the beginning of meditation,
like Hinayana meditation.
But as we get closer
to 12:00, there
are practices designed to
just push you over the edge,
like, for example, the Dzogchen
teachings in Tibetan Buddhism,
or the self-enquiry
method of Ramana Maharshi.
So that's the power of practice.
And you can start to see now
the way that all this works is,
if your intention in life
is brilliance-- people
have a lot of-- there' are
a lot of ways to live life.
You could live your
life for pleasure.
life for money.
You could live
your life for fame.
You could live your life
in all kinds of ways.
But if you get just
a little taste--
in German, they call it
[GERMAN],, which I think
is a much better
word than taste.
But if you just get this
little taste of the possibility
of a life of contribution--
and Google offers you this
incredibly generous opportunity
with the 20% thing--
a taste of what it's like to
live a life of contribution
to the grandchildren
of your grandchildren,
contributing to
the quality of life
of people who are not yet born.
When we get a little
taste of that,
it becomes a positive addiction.
You understand what I mean?
If you drink alcohol,
it's a negative addiction.
You drink more alcohol,
you smoke more cigarettes,
going oh, I don't
want to be doing this.
But contribution is
a positive addiction.
The more you contribute
and serve other people,
the better you feel about
yourself, the more energy
you have, the more
money flows on its own
without you having to
do anything about it.
Contribution is a
positive addiction.
The more we live a
life of contribution,
the more we become
interested in fostering
this quality of
brilliance, the more
we become interested
in helping it along.
And hopefully, what I've
shared with you today,
is a very practical, repeatable,
verifiable way of doing that.
Thanks for listening today.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about the clock analogy
that you used with the cycle.
Did you intentionally
make that to mirror,
the structure of a day?
Because it seems
like [INAUDIBLE]..
ARJUNA ARDAGH: No, no.
Actually, that's a
great point, thank you.
And in that way, I could
have gone north, east, south,
and west or something.
No, it actually-- in that
way, it's a little misleading,
because it doesn't--
in fact, if you think
about it, 12 o'clock
is something that I visit
early in the morning.
Intentionally, I get up at
4 o'clock in the morning--
4:30, actually-- and
if you do get a chance
to look at the book,
you'll find out why.
But very, very
early in the morning
is the best time
to access 12:00.
Before the sun comes
up, it's a great time.
And there are a lot of
traditions that support that.
The time from 12:00 to
3:00 doesn't need very long
to activate unless
you're actually
writing a book or something.
You only need, like, 15
minutes of 12:00 to 3:00
to activate it.
But that's also a good thing
to do right around the dawn.
As, literally, as the sun is
coming up over the horizon,
that's a great time to
be in 12:00 to 3:00,
where you're ushering in
these creative impulses.
You can write some
notes or do something.
Most of our day, because
of the society we live in,
in the post-Industrial
Revolution, most of our day
is spent in 3:00 to 6:00.
I mean, you're going to spend
a great part of your day
in 3:00 to 6:00.
But it doesn't matter.
So long as those other
quadrants have been opened,
it doesn't matter.
The best time for the 6:00
to 9:00-- the brown phase
is at the end of the day.
So whenever you shut
off your computer
and say I'm done with working,
that's a time to reflect.
And we have practices
in our coaching method
that encourage you to
actually feel, ugh,
to feel this kind of, ugh,
embarrassment or shame
and to learn from it.
And finally, the movement
from 9:00 to 12:00,
that is actually
something that you
can enter into sleep with and
also come out of sleep with.
So yeah, no, the times
don't measure the 24 cycle,
but it's an analogy.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Arjuna.
[APPLAUSE]